how are you
hi once again y'all are all in a music
video and I am not a part of it it is
that is so cool nice to meet you you
could be a tag team your Machi Machi
over here I know but then you've got the
gold and the black in it it's very nice
it all ties in um as I mentioned you you
were the first woman to win a
WrestleMania Main Event so can you
explain very excited
playing for people that don't know what
that is what is that so uh well
WrestleMania it's like our version of
the Super Bowl essentially
and uh and so for 35 years there had
never been a woman or any women to have
main evented our Super Bowl and and so
and they wanted it and and the people
wanted and that was the thing you know
it's the goal of of any wrestler anybody
who gets into the business they want a
main event WrestleMania and I remember
when I first not when I first started
but when I first got signed to WWE I
told one of my friends and a very
supportive Friend by the way yeah that I
wanted to Main Event WrestleMania and he
said it's nice to have dreams but be
realistic and and yeah which which seems
like oh good punch but it was just it
was just seen as such a far away goal
that it just wouldn't be possible but we
made it possible
and the fans made it possible
so tell us about the upcoming it's WWE
Rumble it's the Royal Rumble Royal
Rumble I can't say royal royal I can't
look we found a word hope it's not in a
song I have to sing Royal Rumble I can't
say Royal so what is this for everybody
what can we expect so Royal Rumble it's
it's the lead up to WrestleMania oh by
the way WrestleMania is in Los Angeles
this year it is
say you're right uh if you happen to be
free if anybody happens to be free April
April 1st only if I get to body slam
somewhere I'm just kidding
that sounds fun we can always have beef
Kelly we'll make up some beef anyway I
like this so uh so so the Royal Rumble
is is the lead up to WrestleMania and so
what the Royal Rumble is it's a 30
person Battle Royal but two people start
off and every 90 seconds they a new
person comes in until we get to 30
people and the person who wins that
throws every and to win you have to
throw everybody out the top rope or you
have to outlast everybody yeah be the
last person stand and everybody has to
go over the top rope and then you get to
stand there and point to the
Wrestlemania sign because there's a big
WrestleMania sign everybody always wants
to point to the Wrestlemania sign and so
and so that is the goal but it's it's
the most it's always been my favorite
um live uh premium live event that we've
done and so when I was a little kid I'd
stay up until four o'clock in the
morning back in Ireland watching it and
to be able to do it now and to have
actually been a Royal Rumble winner it's
so cool Beyond a dream come true I love
I'm going to talk about this because you
you were saying when you were younger
you and your brother both he wanted to
get into this wrestling thing and you
were too young and you lied about your
age right to get in I sure did yeah yeah
I love that most girls lie to get into
clubs to go dancing and you were like
I'm lying to get into wrestling I love
it but like I was little I was a little
bit of a daughter and a little bit of a
waster and like I was like I was 15. I
was like I need what is a dosser and a
waster
[Laughter]
you just spoke in code well you know I
I'd just be up to no good I was up to no
good Kelly oh okay and uh I mean really
fun and I needed to not be up to no okay
I know I needed to get on the street
Focus yes okay okay and I thought
professional wrestling will get me on
the street now
oh my God and so I found out they were
open in this wrestling school down about
an hour away from where I live yeah and
so my brother found out and he was going
to go down and I was like I want to go
down he's like you can't go down I don't
want to be looking after me little
sister I was like you won't be looking
after me I was lying already and uh and
and he said well you have to be 16. I
was like I'll lie and he's like they
might ask you for ID so it's like all
right I'll drop it and so I asked my dad
to drive me down and my dad drove me
down and he dropped me off before my
brother got there because he got the
train like a sucker and so and so I went
in and I said I I was 17 because I I
thought if I say I'm 16 they might ask
me Friday but if I say I'm 17 like who
says they're 70. exactly exactly and and
it worked I'm a genius yeah
I
don't want that one of my favorite guys
oh my God you can see Becky in the Royal
Rumble streaming live exclusively on
peacock tomorrow night at eight Eastern
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]